a number of those who campaign to leave
the European Union have been given top
jobs of course in Tereza mais new
cabinet Boris Johnson is the foreign
secretary Liam Fox is the trade
secretary and I'm joined now by the
Secretary of State for leaving the
European Union David Davis MP ok
Department X yeah see where you're going
very good morning to Secretary of State
and tell me that you know mentioning are
you three brexit ears as its termed in
some of the papers today
how are you coordinating this who's in
charge your department the overall thing
I mean Barry paramon Boris his foreign
secretary he's got big other
responsibilities is not just about
brexit and and ditto trade but although
that although trade is an massively
important component all about to do so
that's our work that it's basically who
the person who's in charge I mean to be
clear about this is actually Theresa May
and and you see this straight away
because on Friday she went up to see she
broke the reshuffle I mean how many
times 2-minute problems to go in the
middle of a reshuffle
she broke the sequence the reshuffle to
go to see Nicola Sturgeon to talk about
Scotland's perspective and what we can
do to make it easier for Scotland I mean
well you've mentioned it I was gonna
talk about it later but I mean do you
think there is a way we heard Nicola
Sturgeon talking today on the marsh Oh
Nicola Sturgeon still believes there
might be some kind of way she didn't
very vague that Scotland could stay in
the European Union the UK I don't think
that works I mean one of one of our
really and on challenging issues to deal
with will be the internal border we have
with southern ireland and what i'm going
to go about creating other internal
borders inside the united kingdom but
the aim here is to try to address the
concerns of people who were basically
remain people who are saying well we're
worried about your wood investment we're
worried about
trade with Europe we're worried about
all sorts of things and we'll try and as
best we can
they can't have a veto because the 17.5
million people have given us a mandate
they told us what to do we can't disobey
it but what we can do is try and do what
we can to minimize any disruption
turbulence probably can't have another
independence worth
Westminster won't legislature man that
that's I don't I don't think they would
want one to be honest I'm I think
there's a lot of lot of skirmishing
around this I mean think about the
circumstance that Scotland's in now when
oil price was very very high then they
still were in deficit now our price is
very very low their enormous lien
deficits I'll be very surprised that the
Scots would vote let's get on to the big
picture the timetable first of all you
envisage the UK formally leaving the
European Union on the 1st of January 29
early next year I mean let me just
explain that article 52 yeah that's the
trigger that the treaty and then and
there are two big reasons for that the
sort of outer parts of that envelope one
is you know we are we've got a huge
negotiation to do somebody described it
as the biggest negotiation ever in
history and so we're going to get all of
it right we only have one chance you
know get one of these things wrong and
it lasts forever all right so we've got
to get it all rights as a big
consultation going on I mean I was
talking on Friday night to the head of
the tea you see and I'm seeing various
party members this week not just Tory
party members other party members I'm
seeing we're organizing huge
consultation wouldn't talking the CBI
the nfu the the research institutes
everybody didn't think so you know
you're in favor of small government
you're going to be recruiting for
thousands of bureaucrats no no talking
about getting it right and all these and
dance to do with every country in the
world happened at the moment is 40
people so that is a serious point is
that people like new countries like New
Zealand offering some trade negotiators
because we've got very few and they work
we will be doing that which I'll come
back to in a second but but it will grow
to a couple hundred people that will be
the size of the department is your
course but it interestingly I am having
the most brilliant people in white or
applying to work got 10 people for every
job so we're actually it clearly
fast-track civil servants see this is
the place to be so we'll have good
quality but let me come back to the
timetable because that sort of starts
with you so we've got to get that done
properly so that makes it sort of
beginning of next year early ish right
the end of the the the the timetable is
set of course by the to year an article
50 takes two years but there's an
advantage to it said to us in this and P
people not seen this yet Liam's going
around the world he is gonna be making
trade deals huge trade deals all over
the place and when we get nut but none
of them can come into effect whilst
inside the European Union and I'm going
to be even be talking to them well
that's what they say they can't tell us
who to talk to you know they make news
right so yeah what they're gonna do
threatens actly but the but they know
we're so we're talking to large numbers
of people who oughta help and will get a
very very very large trade area much
much bigger than European Union probably
ten times the size well I'm gonna sit
them targets but but a multiple of the
size of the European Union and the
moment we leave they'll all come in now
that's actually an enormous upside to
this thing and so that that's why the
timetables got got it okay talk now
because you're writing today weren't you
in the mail on Sunday about EU nationals
legally of course living and working
here and you're saying this whole idea
and Theresa maze muddied the waters as
well hasn't she saying that we might
have to even visit the issue of EU
nationals that live here already you're
saying indefinite leave to remain
protection only applies before a certain
day what was that date lately let's put
the backdrop to it first but if I may I
mean number one I want to see a generous
settlement for the for the people here
already yeah because they didn't pick
this circumstance we did you know they
came here thinking they could be here
for life and whatever some have been
here for many many decades so we want to
get a generous settlement for them we
want to do that the same time as we get
a similarly generous settlement for
British citizens leaving within the EU
now there's been a concern raised that
that the generous the sheer generosity a
settlement you know leave to remain
pension rights whatever it might be but
are you saying just pause a minute
because those that are already here from
the EU that's not in question Theresa
Macy's no that might we we have to do it
all - yeah I'm tell you what my aim is
right at the moment I have a lot of aims
there's not a blanket assurance now that
if you're from the EU and you live in
this country you can we go all right let
me just let me say this I would expect
to get to a circumstance where
everybody's well protected but if we
separate it out or if we preempt it then
you put somebody else at risk so
somebody said oh you're using people as
bargaining counters no we're not
we're stopping anybody being used as bar
encounters by doing all together so so
that's where we start but if we make a
very generous settlement as I'd like to
do then people didn't say oh but then
that'll attract lots more people in
because they want to beat the deadline
and so what I've said is let's deal with
that issue when we come to it
one issue could one way of dealing with
it could be saying okay only people
arrive before a certain date get this
protection there are other ways to but
we've got to do it within the law as it
stands because at that point we'll still
be within but this certain date and you
be none specific about what that certain
date might be you've started the rush
now haven't you because people listening
are gonna be saying right yeah I want to
come and live in the in the UK and there
is going to be a date we don't know what
it certainly isn't now if you said come
down I tell you if you set a date that's
but that's what you start the rush
that's all that but you've got to leave
my saying there is going to be one no I
don't think so because people will
understand look that if they come here
in a big rush to start try and grab a
set of advantages that we're putting in
place for people who have come here
expecting us just remain within the
European Union forever and they've done
exactly the right thing you know they
come to work they do a good job they're
paying their taxes we mustn't if we're
going to possibly avoid it
penalize them and so I don't intend to
wishes so how will you know Britain will
not have left the Europe well you know
that a than a French person walking down
the street didn't arrive after oh well
let's pick June the time we have think
about how will you know we have we have
plenty of well they'll have employment
records to start most of them or other
records they'll be plenty of roses there
won't be a problem they'll have to
produce those well they don't think we'd
even need to do that I think we'd know
anyway I mean this this problem we don't
even know how many illegal immigrants
are in the country come on mr. Davison
you've been on this program tell me
about that before that's a different
matter illegal immigrants are a problem
but but but no no people are here
legally no we'd have a difficulty there
and bear in mind this is only an issue
if there's a surge there's a node in
issue if there is a surge of people
arriving and I don't think that is by
any means certain I don't think you
don't think you're in danger of causing
wellness by saying that this is
something we're considering it all if
I'm listening or hear about this
interview interviewer in another
European country that I need to get over
there before they shut the door no there
won't be like that and and if I gave you
a date it would if I gave you today it
would know if I said it's gonna happen
next week it would
but you raised 24th well that's that's
that's already past you know so they're
all sort of ways but that's not the only
way to do it there are other ways to
deal with this but we must in many of
these issues as I said you the beginning
six months to actually work out what
we're gonna do how we're gonna start it
many as issues is not easy answers you
deal with them when it come up and just
ok we only got a little bit of time left
I mean the other broader question here
is do you believe that the UK whatever
you negotiate the UK can keep its access
to the European single market well keep
its access whoever keeps a tariff free
access is the issue and I think yes I
think that's what Raymond for I mean
bear in mind the mandate we've been
given is control the borders get back
control of that country got to meet all
of that but I think in the next year or
two we're going to see the Europeans
change away from their initial sort of
project fear stance if you like towards
the stance now taken by the the German
equivalent the CBI we must talk to the
Brits to make sure free trade works in
both directions they know what we've
always said that that they depend as
much on us more on us actually than we
do on their security state thank you
very much indeed
David Davis there from the Department
for exit is he turned it himself